Stephen Hawking was born exactly 300 years
after the death of astronomer Galileo Galillei.
Although this wasn’t a man who believed
in predestination.
He was born in Oxford, England on January
8, 1942, to well-educated parents.
Isobel Eileen Hawking earned her way to the
University of Oxford at a time when few women
got a degree.
She studied economics, philosophy, and politics
and later worked as a medical research secretary.
Frank Hawking also went to Oxford and studied
medicine, specializing in tropical diseases.
Frank’s research took them to London but
when Isobel became pregnant with Stephen,
she left the capital for Oxford to seek a
safer place.
London was still reeling from the aftermath
of the Blitz in 1941.
After the birth of Stephen, two sisters followed,
Philippa and Mary
as well as an adopted brother, Edward.
Stephen began his education in Highgate, a
suburb of London, at the Byron House School,
a very progressive school.
Hawking said the teachers didn’t believe
in drilling things into the students and he
blamed this on his inability to read until
he was eight years old.
When he was eight, the family moved north
of London, to St Albans, Hertfordshire, when Frank became
head of the Department of Parasitology at
the National Institute for Medical Research.
He wanted Stephen to go into medicine as well,
but his son was already enamored by the stars
and spent much of his time looking at the
sky and beyond.
The Hawkings were eccentric.
Instead of chatting while having dinner, they
each sat silently reading a book.
They lived in a large, messy house and kept
bees in the basement.
And they traveled around in an old London
taxi.
Stephen’s family placed a high value on
education.
When he was 13, his father wanted him to get
into the highly regarded Westminster School,
immediately next to Westminster Abbey.
But Stephen fell ill and didn’t sit for
a scholarship exam.
Without it, they couldn’t afford the school
fees.
So he remained as a student at St Albans School.
And perhaps that was a good thing.
It was at St Albans that he met an inspirational
teacher, Dikran Tahta.
Hawking said Tahta opened his eyes to the
blueprint of the universe: mathematics.
Together, they built Hawking’s first computer
from old clock parts and a telephone switchboard.
Hawking would say: “Behind every exceptional
person, there is an exceptional teacher.”
He originally wanted to study mathematics
at university but his father was worried that there
weren’t many jobs for math grads.
Stephen would win a scholarship to study physics
at Oxford.
For his first 18 months as a university student,
he was bored and found the work ridiculously
easy.
He was also lonely and didn’t have much
of a social life
That changed when he decided to join his college’s
boat club.
His loud voice and lightweight made him the
perfect coxswain - the person in charge of
the boat.
A fellow boatman remarked that he often seemed
like he had “...his head in the stars, working
out mathematical formulae.”
But he didn’t put a lot of effort into his
studies.
He said he spent only an hour a day on average
working during his entire time at Oxford.
That made exams difficult and it nearly jeopardized
a first-class degree which he needed to get
admitted to the University of Cambridge for
postgraduate studies.
His results were on the border between first
and second-class honours so he had to take
an oral exam.
During the oral, he was asked to describe
his plans.
He responded: "If you award me a First, I
will go to Cambridge.
If I receive a Second, I shall stay in Oxford,
so I expect you will give me a First."
Hawking received a first-class Bachelor’s
degree in physics in 1962 and began grad work
at Cambridge in cosmology, the study of the
universe.
He was disappointed to find he had been assigned
physicist Dennis Sciama as his supervisor
rather than the more famous astronomer Fred
Hoyle.
However, this turned out to be a blessing
in disguise.
Hoyle was rarely at the department while Sciama
was always eager to talk which helped stimulate
Hawking’s own scientific vision.
Hoyle was also not a fan of the Big Bang theory
- the theory that the universe had a beginning
when it exploded with unimaginable force.
He was the one who coined the term ‘big
bang’ to poke fun at the theory.
On the other hand, Sciama was happy for Hawking
to investigate the beginning of time.
But before he could delve deeply into his
research, he received devastating news.
He noticed he had been getting increasingly
clumsy during his time at Oxford.
He fell down some stairs and the only suggestion
the doctor had was that he lay off the beer.
However, in 1963, while at Cambridge, Hawking
was diagnosed with a motor neuron disease
called amyotrophic lateral sclerosis or ALS
which gradually paralyzes a person as the
brain can no longer control the muscles.
Doctors gave him two years to live.
He was just 21 years old.
Hawking became deeply depressed.
He felt there was no point in continuing his
studies.
He wrote in his memoir: "I felt it was very
unfair — why should this happen to me?
At the time, I thought my life was over and
that I would never realise the potential I
felt I had."
However, the disease progressed slower than
expected.
Sciama encouraged Hawking to return to his
research.
Hawking’s greatest work revolutionized how
we think about black holes: a perfectly circular
region of space that’s formed when a star
collapses at the end of its life cycle.
Albert Einstein’s General Theory of Relativity
had predicted black holes.
The theory explains how gravity distorts spacetime.
The gravitational pull of a black hole is
so strong that nothing can escape it, not
even light.
And it warps the surroundings like a carnival
mirror.
Einstein wasn’t entirely convinced that
these mysterious monsters existed.
The work of British mathematician Sir Roger
Penrose proved general relativity really does
lead to the formation of black holes.
And for that, he won a Nobel Prize, in 2020.
Hawking became obsessed with black holes.
And made a number of important discoveries
about them
including that they’re not entirely black.
He discovered that they emit light just outside
the event horizon - which is the boundary
between normal space and the space affected
by the black hole’s gravity where nothing
can escape.
He believed the slow leak of what’s now
known as Hawking radiation would cause the
black hole to evaporate over time.
He had a knack for making bets about black
holes, too.
He and physicist Kip Thorne teamed up to bet
that black holes swallow information, losing
it forever, while physicist John Preskill
thought that was nonsense and believed this
information would be recovered through the
radiation.
This puzzle remains unresolved but Hawking
conceded the bet and as a concession gift,
gave Preskill an encyclopedia of his choice:
one on baseball.
Hawking used his research on black holes to
answer a bigger question: where did our universe
originate?
He took inspiration from Penrose’s work
which showed that deep inside a black hole,
a singularity exists.
Where all conceptions of space and time break
down.
Hawking applied the same thinking to the universe:
it also began in a singularity, adding credence
to the big bang theory that the universe began
at a single point in time.
But that doesn’t mean he believed there
was a creator behind it all.
He wrote: “Because there is a law such as
gravity, the universe can and will create
itself from nothing...It is not necessary
to invoke God to light the blue touch paper
and set the universe going.”
Blue touch paper is a reference to fireworks.
That’s a different outlook than the father
of the Big Bang theory, who felt the law of
gravity was created by a creator.
I talked about the life of Georges Lemaître,
a scientist and priest, in a previous video
which I’ll link in the description.
Hawking was known to muse about God’s existence,
once telling Reuters: “The laws may have
been decreed by God, but God does not intervene
to break the laws.”
(Reuters 2007)
However, in the end, he was an atheist, although
he did fall in love with a Christian.
Stephen met Jane Wilde at a party in their
hometown of St Albans.
He, a physics student at Cambridge, she, an
English student at the University of London.
They met around the time of his health prognosis.
Hawking said Jane gave him something to live
for.
They got married in 1965 and thought they
didn’t have a lot of time together.
Turns out, they would be married for 30 years
and have 3 children.
His health problems were a constant strain
on their marriage.
Jane said she sought strength from her faith
as Stephen’s illness worsened and she became
his caregiver: feeding him, dressing him,
bathing him, being by his side through his
many hospital visits.
But she also once said their marriage was
strained for another reason.
She remarked: “The truth was, there were
four partners in our marriage.
Stephen and me, motor neuron disease and physics.”
She remarked: “The truth was, there were
four partners in our marriage.
Stephen and me,
motor neuron disease and physics.”
She felt shut out of his scientific world
where his work didn’t slow down despite
his physical decline.
When he lost his ability to write, he developed
unique ways of thinking.
He had to rely on doing complicated equations
in his head.
A physicist compared this to Mozart composing
an entire symphony in his mind!
Although the cruel disease robbed him of his
ability to move and slurred his speech, his
intellect remained sharp.
He was elected to the Royal Society, the UK’s
national science academy, at the age of 32.
And in 1979, he rose to become the Lucasian
Professor of Mathematics at Cambridge - the
most famous academic chair in the world - once
held by Sir Isaac Newton.
He would give lectures and speeches with the
help of a computer-generated voice.
Can you hear me?
He opted not to change his voice to a more
natural-sounding one later on because this
had already become his trademark.
He didn’t actually lose his ability to speak
entirely until 1985 when he caught pneumonia
while on a trip to a research center in Switzerland.
He was so ill he had to be put on life support.
When doctors asked his wife if they should
remove his ventilator, Jane refused.
They had to cut a hole in his neck and place
a tube in his windpipe to help him breathe.
The tracheotomy removed what was left of his
speech.
In order to communicate, he chose letters
on a spelling card by raising his eyebrows.
Later, he received a computer program from
American engineer Walter Woltosz (wall-toesszz),
whose mother suffered from ALS.
Hawking could choose words from the database
with a click.
But then he lost control of his hand and had
to resort to twitching his cheek muscle to
select the letters.
This was painfully slow, and he could only
manage a word or two a minute.
So he reached out to Intel for help.
Researchers worked on a state-of-the-art system
that would interpret his intentions, kind
of like the iPhone’s predictive text feature.
Intel worked with London startup SwiftKey
on a word predictor which analyzed Hawking’s
papers to get a better idea of his writing
habits.
For example, when he selected the word ‘black’
it automatically predicted that ‘hole’
would follow.
It was thanks to technology that Hawking could
put his ground-breaking research into book
form.
He published his best-known work in 1988.
A Brief History of Time sold a million copies
in just the first year - remarkable for a
book about science - although many readers
didn’t finish it.
It was very dense, even after Hawking omitted
all equations except one in order to appeal
to the masses.
He only left in Einstein’s iconic e = mc2.
Hawking was already well-known before the
book’s release but became a celebrity afterward.
He appeared on the Simpsons, the Big Bang
theory, and Star Trek.
He became a “cult-like” figure who also
had a mischievous streak.
He was rumored to use his wheelchair to run
over the toes of people who annoyed him.
Prince Charles was apparently a victim.
His fame also put both his professional and
personal life in the spotlight.
Hawking ended up leaving Jane for one of the
nurses who cared for him, Elaine Mason.
Mason’s husband was the engineer who attached
Hawking’s speech synthesizer to his wheelchair.
Hawking said he grew more and more unhappy
at the relationship between Jane and Jonathan
Jones, an organist at the local church, who
actually moved in with the Hawkings, when
Stephen was expected to die young, and Jane
wanted someone who could support the children.
Jane married Jones after Hawking married Elaine
in 1995.
His second marriage is said to have caused
friction with his children.
They, too, would divorce after a decade together.
And later resumed a closer relationship with
his first wife and his children.
During an interview with Diane Sawyer on ABC
News, he talked about the most important advice
he gave his kids.
He said: "One, remember to look up at the
stars and not down at your feet.
Two, never give up work.
Work gives you meaning, and purpose and life
is empty without it.
Three, if you are lucky enough to find love,
remember it is rare and don't throw it away."
And with the world, he once shared this:
“And however difficult life may seem, there
is always something you can do, and succeed
at.
It matters that you don't just give up.”
He put it in another, more humorous way once
at the University of Oxford.
If you feel you are in a black hole, don’t
give up
After 50 years of living with ALS, Hawking
passed away peacefully at his home, on March
14, 2018, at the age of 76.
His funeral took place at a church in Cambridge.
Guests included the actors from the film about
his life, The Theory of Everything.
The movie’s title is a reference to a single
theory that Hawking hoped to find to have
a complete understanding of the universe.
One theory to explain how it all worked.
It’s one of the major unsolved problems
in physics today.
Despite all that he had accomplished there
were things he dreamt of doing but never did.
He never got the chance to fly to space, although
he did travel aboard Zero Gravity’s Boeing
727 to experience weightlessness.
He was a strong advocate of space travel and
living on other planets.
By the end of the century, I truly hope
humans will be living on Mars.
He was seriously worried about what he saw
as potential threats to humanity: nuclear
war, climate change, epidemics, asteroids,
and the rise of artificial intelligence.
Hawking’s ashes were buried in Westminster
Abbey not far from the graves of two other
famous scientists, Newton and Charles Darwin.
While he didn’t believe in predestination,
the brilliant scientist who was born on the
day Sir Isaac Newton died, died on the day
Albert Einstein was born.
If you’ve been inspired by the life of Stephen
Hawking and want to learn more about how the
universe works, my sponsor Brilliant can help
you improve your math, science, and computer
science skills.
Brilliant is an interactive way to learn.
In this course on scientific thinking, you
can explore the laws of physics as you play.
Or you can learn about the major pillars of
calculus, like derivatives or integrals, through
visual illustrations.
If there isn’t any specific subject you’d
like to brush up on, you can have some fun
with the Mathematical Fundamentals course
that has a chapter on Logic where you can
strengthen your critical thinking through
puzzles and riddles.
And if you're ever stumped, you can read the
explanations for the correct way of going
about the answer.
Brilliant is great for both students and professionals,
for both beginners and those who want to build
on what they already know.
You can try out Brilliant for FREE using my
custom link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
The first 200 people who use my link will
get 20% off Brilliant Premium which unlocks
all of the courses.
Thanks so much for watching.
For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.